with what Utah has out here tonight
um it feels consistent it was a good
pass right there that was quick too that
was early in the shot clock I like it
Hibachi shooting 38 from three-point
range knocks it down this is one of the
most prolific three-point shooting teams
in the league the Utah Jazz as nerk
rumbles into the lane goes right at
olyny fifth in offensive rebounds 12 a
game one reason they get those rebounds
kept because they have people chasing
around a lot a good response here again
from the Blazers Watford over here to
thibo
yeah
wow got his wheels here in the thin air
of Utah from Satan running the floor
helping to clear things up nurse
delivery was on point and that's after
Here Comes obagi's ball Strip by David
rolls right to done he has it stripped
and reddish comes up with it active
Blazer hands leading to a two on one and
there's Eubanks with a jab and a lead
pass from Dave
game up the floor working on Tuesday
into the lane laid it up and in he
slowed up cap he was on that left wing
he looked like he was sprinting in he
slowed down and a defense can kind of
check off of him for a second and then
he accelerated to the basket so here's
traded but it's recovered and sent to
Market it for three long board grab by
Dave Quick Pass outside delivering the
Fable for the two-hand flush Blazers
have had a number of double-digit leads
this year
says we've taken care of business in the
first half now we've just got to sustain
it here in the second half something
we've had difficulty doing
Dan gets new dribbles from Fievel backs
off Kessler pulls up and sticks a three
there he goes there he goes indeed Shams
on the brakes
and it sticks to Jimmy 35 for him
lasers up eight name into the lane being
ridden by a Lenny who plays through that
contact to laid it in
[Applause]
Pittsburgh with a 10 assist night
bouncing over to Watford into the Lane
High one up and he's fouled in the act
trending Watford
having quite a night and the timing was
perfect because marketing didn't even
really see him
turns the corner what a beautiful job
that was he turned to the sidelines as
teammates that my fault should have made
the bounce pass he even played it out
well the other guard on the roster the
other PD
Damian Lillard scoring their confidence
and hanging on and maintaining those
double-digit leads Lamar and their young
guys were at the core of this yeah they
were
yeah they were that's what they hope it
is at this point of the season they see
some signs of growth
despite where they are in the win loss
column right now there's play on the
floor taking one game at a time
they they want to show Improvement and
this looks like